King - ugly crying face flush out no no
flippin channel wonderful I love this
you I couldn't - what I know about them
very stupid everything related with this
what is a big in a Spanish culo
unintentionally I think we're Kardashian
experts we've seen every episode so if
the whole family
I mean if a mother three girls and a boy
have you seen Keeping Up with the
Kardashians no no are you excited to
watch the show of course I am so I'm
here to be your guy okay gonna help you
through this like I said what I made me
laugh because for me it's kind of joke
so that's Kim that she dropped her
$75,000 diamond earring in the ocean she
saw like a baby there what a challenge
to pose for Playboy what would you think
if I posed nude for Playboy hmm what do
you think of that outfit looks very very
open looks nice but it looks nice on her
on her phone on you I saw that
television I saw this is jail time one
of my favorite moments in Kardashian
history
defend your sister I mean the charity
took a picture it's what is Oh for the
dance they thought that she was drunk
and they know so they pretended that it
was placenta that they were making for
everyone but they switched it out at the
last second they are not going to have
the same Terry of the same time I think
that they made looks delicious what
would you have done if someone had done
that to you well I will press charges
because sisters are fighting as usual
defending us out of control I would have
spent God right back
boom boom crisper mom kind of got in a
fight with Kim her daughter and they're
all on vacation together I didn't know
where's your purse you're gonna see your
phone oh man it's war if I ever threw
your phone we would never see the next
day like we'd kill each other you don't
think it's funny even a little bit
mmm no wait funny arrow we come from two
different worlds which is for me this is
a circle for you you had to like make
your house out of stone so this is Kim
she's with her sister in Kourtney here
we go ugly cry hmm
she cry all the time I don't know why I
like a baby all the time you thought
there were only three sisters there's
five I think this is a clip of the
youngest Kardashians do Cecil know nine
years old do that not up there that's
like a stripper pole she just like crabs
the baby out of her vagina that's Peggy
you got a big therefore oh it right into
her arms like a football here the babe
she just wanted - yeah baby - she was in
a hurry
nice nice nice to watch well you can use
entertaining it's definitely something
like we bond over I even watch this show
i watch one side on channel 81 sure
everyone yes depends a lot you're the
society sending a little message that is
nice to be like the family doing good
things for obesity friends look how
beautiful we are
look how the family is look what I have
one enemy the mother could be a cultural
level home so maybe she wouldn't watch
this but if it were in Spanish you know
Nandu Lina Spanish the Kardashians could
be funny and you could be also sick yeah
[Music]